great father once a
it ain't about how hard
it's about how hard
you're not built for this these boys
come in here they got a fight for life
people die in the ring your daddy died
in the green I don't know how I got
nothing doing me just taking from the
10th round the first fight right how'd
you know that I heard about a third
fight between you and Apollo behind
closed doors the girl said you wanted to
talk about something yeah I want to talk
to you about training me my son your
father was special their truth I don't
know if you're special
only you really know that but you've got
to work hard I swear to God if you're
not gonna do it come on
you know how many times I had to carry
your father up these stairs because he
couldn't walk you are your father's son
but it doesn't mean you have to be human
you just got your staring back at you
that's the toughest opponent you ever
gonna have to face I believe that's true
Lorraine and I think that's true life to
show me something I'm gonna fight my
whole life it's not a choice for me if I
break are you gonna fix it everything I
got is moved on and I'm here why bother
sitting there cry about nobody's a
Ralphie I'm here for you every day I'm
standing right in front of you
it's about how hard you can get hit and
keep moving forward how much you can
take they keep moving
that's how winning is done
without your turn it's your turn